[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON: For much
of human history,
the idea of physical proximity
and attentional proximity
were seen as one and the same.
Where I am is what
I pay attention to.
Who I'm with is who
But the notion of who I'm
with-- the notion of where
my mind is-- is being
transformed to the back
of wireless technologies.
Who are you?
Where are you when you're
talking on the telephone?
Are you at the other end of the
world at someone else's ear,
or are you over here?
Essentially,
attentional proximity
on the back of
these technologies
has been disjointed
from physical proximity.
Our mind no longer has
to be engaging with where
we physically are at.
Our mind has been
unhinged-- liberated--
from the constraints of
time, space, and distance.
We have transcended geography.
Now granted, we are still
interfacing with other minds,
transcending physical
proximity-- physical location--
with, you know, magical devices
made of plastic and metal.
But eventually, flow
immersive virtual reality--
the ability to engage with
somebody on the other side
of the planet, in a space that
isn't space, that nonetheless
feels like a three-dimensional
matrix-- will lead us to a time
when the new thing is going to
be called shared co-presence.
It's this notion that
mind-to-mind communication
and mediation will be
free of any constraints.
This is a kind of
technologically-enabled
transcendence of mind over
matter-- mind trumps matter,
minds trumps biology, mind
trumps any and all limits,
you know.
And it's a wild idea,
because most people are still
freaked out about these
disruptive and transformative
technologies.
But in the end we're
liberating ourselves.
We're gettin rid of our
biological staight jackets.
You know, we're
learning the songs
that orchestrate the universe.
We're becoming beings
that are in superposition.
We're experiencing non-locality
at the level of consciousness.
I mean, this is us.
Right?
We're literalizing the
prophecies of quantum physics.
It's a wild idea--
something worth thinking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]